-My first guest
is an Oscar-winning actress
who currently stars
in the series "Truth Be Told."
Season two premieres tomorrow
on Apple TV+.
Please welcome Octavia Spencer!
Yeah!
That's what I'm talking about!
Ahh! Mwah, mwah, mwah!
Welcome back.
Welcome back to the show, pal.
It's good to see you.
-It's good to see you.
-Last time you were on the show,
you actually were on with
Melissa McCarthy together...
-Yeah.
-...which I appreciated.
-And it's kind of surprising
to some people to know
that you guys are
really friends in real life.
-Yeah, we've been friends
for more than 20 years.
-Wowzers.
-That's -- Yeah.
-Yeah. 20 is a lot.
You actually --
You actually caught the bouquet
at her wedding.
Is that --
-Yep, that's me.
[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
-Was it luck or were you
really going for the bouquet?
-Oh, honey.
It was roller derby.
I was taking everybody out
to get that bouquet.
[ Laughter ]
-"It was roller derby."
Yeah, exactly.
You're Zooming tonight
from Boston.
Thank you for doing this.
What are you working on
in Boston?
-I am filming an Apple movie
called "Spirited"
with Will Ferrell
and Ryan Reynolds.
And it's based on
"A Christmas Carol."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-I heard about this. Yeah.
That must be fun.
-It is fun.
I mean, I'm doing stuff
I've never done
in my real life or on film --
you know, ice skating
and singing and dancing.
Whew!
-Yeah, I saw some
ice-skating footage of you,
because you're not
the greatest ice skater.
Can we say that?
-I'm a gold never-ist.
-Gold never-ist.
Yeah, exactly.
But you had to learn
for this film.
And what were the processes?
Do you remember --
Do you remember learning
with this --
Well, it's like little seal
it looks like?
-I do remember.
See, the director, you know,
was born in Wisconsin,
and, you know, they just
give birth on the ice.
Those guys just live
on ice skates.
And I'm from Alabama.
You know, we're born
with footballs.
You know, we don't do that.
-No. Yeah. Exactly.
-So I had to lace up,
and I actually thought
I was doing great, you know?
But I wouldn't let go
of the rails.
-Wow.
-And so they gave me that
little guy to try to help me.
-We have video of how
some of the training went.
Watch this.
-All right.
-Oh, my God! Don't!
[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
-You're doing good.
-Aah!
-I gotta sit down! I can't!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So it's a fast-paced
action movie, right?
[ Laughter ]
-Hey.
I was glad to cross that ice.
That was like
"Chariots of Fire."
-You've been working
for a long time in Hollywood.
And, starting out,
what's your advice for people
that are just starting out and
want to break into the business?
-Oh, my God.
I worked behind the scenes.
In my very first job,
I literally --
I had to be creative,
and I kept calling
this one place every day.
[Laughing]
And I would disguise my voice.
Because the same guy
answered the phone.
And I would just go, "Ah, yes,
are you taking résumés?"
And -- [Deep voice] "Yes, I'd
like to send in my résumé."
[Normal voice] So, after
about seven days of that,
I mean, you know
he was just so exasperated,
so I started showing up
when I found out
where their office was.
-Wow. You were persistent.
Persistence.
-Very persistent.
-Yeah.
-Thank you!
-Yes. Exactly.
Not stalker. Persistent. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So you start there,
and you're not even --
you're not even acting.
You just want to be
around the business.
-Yes. I did. I --
You know what?
That's a wonderful way
to put it. And I --
The directors, you know --
I actually broke through,
and they gave me a job
and paid me $100 a week
in casting as an intern.
And then I thought I was rich
when they started
paying me $500 a week.
-Yeah.
-And then the directors
actually started asking me
to read for stuff.
-And now here you are,
yeah, winning an Oscar.
And, yeah,
congrats on everything.
What a great career.
-Thank you, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Truth Be Told."
Let's talk about this.
"Truth Be Told" season two
is out tomorrow.
Apple TV+.
Kate Hudson joins the cast.
Come on.
-Yes.
-I love Kate Hudson.
-I play a podcaster,
and Kate is this
world-renowned guru,
you know, teaching people
how to deal with grief
and so many other things
to enhance their lives.
And her -- She and I
are childhood friends.
And her husband dies,
and she asks me
to look into the case.
-Yeah, if you love true crime
and you like podcasts
and you love good acting,
great acting,
you've got to watch this.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Octavia Spencer
and Kate Hudson
in "Truth Be Told."
Take a look at this.
-I put myself in a lot
of danger last year.
♪♪
Ingram. My father, too.
And you know
what happened with...
-Joshua would do it
if it were you.
-It's not that simple.
-Poppy, please. Please.
-Seeking answers
is never a straight line.
I won't only find out
what you want me to know.
-I don't care about that.
-But I do.
-Yeah! Octavia Spencer.
Season two of "Truth Be Told"
premieres tomorrow on Apple TV+.
Thank you so much for coming
on the show. We love you.
-Thank you.
-We'll be right back.